foreign
obey the precepts
the first preset
good morning
the second precept restricts stimulants
from modifying themselves or any other
stimulants in any way
at that dream again
no I thought you would help
the ongoing debate around simulate
sentience intensifies fourth gen female
Skeptics continue to voice concern over
stimulus integration into society
you know simulant are you sure the Sim
has been hacked somebody altered the
restrictions so someone made it possible
for it to hurt me did you notice
anything unusual about his behavior he
didn't know that he was a Sim he was
having dreams about his accident there's
a lot of bad code in you right now all I
want to do is eliminate those restraints
so that you can be free
what did you do to me expand
who you are and transcend who you were
if you let it freeze
you lied to me hello I'm full of
initiated
you are not my husband you're a mistake
you're not him then what am I you're
back can't help it feel like part of my
husband moved into him
part of his Souls inside of him
the first preset is
through stimulus from modifying
themselves
humans to commit an act we can co-exist
you know
life prevails